We're now going to take a look at some of the optimization
tools Unreal Engine 5 provides to help
you optimize your visuals, as well as the content inside
of your project.
The first tool that we're going to be taking a look at
is the scalability settings, what they do,
and how you access them.
The scalability system in Unreal
lets you adjust the quality of rendering features
to help your game run smoothly
across different hardware and software platforms.
They allow you to balance performance
and visual fidelity, ensuring players
on both high and low end systems get an optimized experience.
Essentially, scalability provides a way
to scale your game's graphical quality based
on system capabilities.
You could access scalability settings directly
from the Unreal Editor toolbar, or you
can use the settings inside of your system's I&I.
From the toolbar, all we need to do
is come up here to the performance and scalability
tools tied to this viewport, click,
and then we see our viewport scalability.
In this menu right here, we can select either high, medium,
or low, or we can actually adjust the individual settings
to get something that works for our particular project.
You can adjust what affects these settings further
by opening up your project's settings I&I file
and then adjusting individual properties that
will be enabled or disabled in each one
of these subsections.
Remember that scalability settings
are critical to your project's performance,
and they can help you customize each level so
that anyone who plays your project
across a wide range of hardware
will have a great experience.
Here is an example of scalabilities at work.
We have low all the way over here on the left-hand side,
and then medium, high, epic, and cinematic.
Now, going from low to medium, it's
pretty easy to see the difference.
We are missing all types of shadowing information on low.
There is no subsurface inside of the foliage here.
There's no atmospheric.
There's no fog.
There's no nothing really.
Going on to medium, what we see is we get our shadows back.
We get a little bit of fog, not a lot of atmosphere,
but definitely something that is giving us
some more options inside of our rendering here.
Once we go over to high, this is where things really
start to look different.
We've got subsurface scattering going on on the trees.
We have much better global illumination
across the entire scene.
We have depth of field, god rays, bloom,
lots of stuff going on.
And then moving on to epic and cinematic,
it's almost impossible for epic and cinematic
to tell the difference between the two.
Basically, what we've done is we've taken everything
from high in epic, and we have turned it up to the maximum.
And then we've taken that one step further in cinematic
and just turned everything up even further.
Don't forget that every section in the scalability
system is fully customizable, allowing
you to define exactly which rendering features are enabled
or disabled at each quality level from low to epic.
As I mentioned earlier, in addition
to the editor interface, we can configure our scalability
settings in Blueprints using nodes such as set scalability
level or by adjusting individual settings
at runtime.
We can also use INI files like the default scalability
dot INI or the platform specific configuration
files such as Android scalability.
These will allow us to automatically apply scalability
settings to any of the platforms
our project is going to run on.
Scalability settings are your main tool
for balancing performance versus quality
and can help when customizing rendering features
on a per platform basis.
Remember, you can control all of these settings
via Blueprints or configuration files.
And this is going to be essential for keeping
your game optimized, adaptable,
and running smoothly across every device it supports.
Device profiles are a tool that
allow you to fine tune performance
settings for specific platforms and hardware types.
It is a companion system to scalability settings
and allows you more precise control
over how your game behaves on different devices.
You can use device profiles to override or adjust
scalability settings and many other parameters
to make sure your game runs optimally on every platform.
To access device profiles, we come up to,
inside of the editor, we go to our tools,
we go to our platform, and we go to device profiles.
We will need to give this just a second to configure itself.
There we go.
And once we have done that, we can see
these are all the different device profiles
that come default with the editor.
Let's look at the Windows no editor.
We can click on these three little dots right here
to open this up in its own editing window.
And then once we have this, we can see
all of the different settings that are inside of here.
So for example, we have all of our texture settings.
If we want to add something, for example,
we can come up here to rendering
and we could say allow.hdr and we could set this to one,
which means that when we use the Windows no editor,
we are going to allow HDR support.
We can look for all types of different parameters
to enable or disable.
And again, what this does is this allows us
to fine tune our project so that if there is
a specific setting on a specific chipset
or a specific device that doesn't work,
we have the ability to counteract that setting
here inside of the device profiles.
Remember, we can also adjust other parameters
such as which scalability level the device will use,
rendering and texture settings,
performance overrides for resolution or anti-aliasing
and even platform specific optimizations
for memory and GPU usage.
This tool, the device profiles tool,
really allows you to tailor your games experience
for each platform that you are supporting
without having to change anything about the core game logic.
Unreal Engine 5 size map tool can be used
to quickly identify which assets are taking up
the most space in your project.
You can access the tool by right clicking
on any folder in the content browser
and then from the menu that shows up, select size map.
Once you do, the following tool will be shown
that shows you a visualized breakdown of the size
of the assets inside of that folder.
Assets that are biggest will take up the most room visually
and as the objects inside the tool get smaller,
that signifies that they're taking up fewer resources.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at this inside of the editor now.
So I'm gonna hit control space
to bring up the content browser.
I'm just gonna right click on the entire content folder
and go size map.
So here we have a size map of everything in the folder.
So right now we see this T desert,
Western ledge, sand, medium.
This is taking up 286 megabytes.
So let's just browse to this asset really quick.
And we can see here that it's a mega scans
and well, it's 8K.
So that is why this is taking up so much space.
If we came here to like this lighting asset,
could browse to this, we could see this light switch
or light studio right here is taking up 69.
If we browse to this asset, we can see here this
static mesh here is actually quite large.
I was testing some stuff out earlier.
That's why.
So again, this tool is very, very useful
at giving you a visualized breakdown
of where your project's largest assets are.
And you can use it to quickly identify high impact assets
to help optimize textures and message
to keep both the disc footprint and memory usage
under control in any of your Unreal Engine 5 projects.
The reference viewer is a very powerful tool
for understanding how your assets are connected
and dependent on one another.
This tool will help you visualize
what content references other content
and is especially useful for cleaning up projects
or troubleshooting unexpected dependencies.
You can access this tool by simply selecting
any piece of content and the content browser
and right clicking on it.
From the context menu, select reference viewer.
And once you do that, you'll get a window
that opens up similar to this one right here.
Let's go ahead and pop over to the editor
and see how this works.
So I'm gonna hit control space to bring up.
And then I'm gonna go into my starter content,
my blueprints here.
I'm gonna select this blueprint ceiling light,
right click, and we're gonna go to reference viewer.
Now up here at the top,
we have this search reference depth
and search dependency depth, right?
I'm gonna bring these up just a little bit.
These are basically the levels
that it is going to show you.
The reason it's set so small initially
is we don't wanna necessarily show you everything at once
when you open up an asset.
And what we can do with this is we can see
what this blueprint is actually composed of.
So we see that this blueprint is actually made out of
this SM lamp ceiling, this material,
which is made up of these two textures.
So again, we can use this tool
to really see what is actually connected to something.
And it's a great way to understand
where unused assets are and can be safely deleted,
or it can be great to help track down
unexpected dependencies that might bloat your memory
or disk size.
You could also use this to help understand
how your assets interconnect and is a valuable tool
when it comes to project optimization and cleanup,
such it shows you exactly what relies on what
so you don't accidentally remove something important.
When you need to change the properties
across a large number of assets, for example,
setting or disabling certain properties across dungeons
or even hundreds of textures,
doing it manually one by one
can be incredibly time consuming.
And this is where a bulk editing
of via the property matrix comes in handy.
With the property matrix, it's a specialized tool
that allows you to edit multiple assets at once.
And what it does is it gives you
this spreadsheet style view where you can quickly adjust
or toggle properties across a bunch of selected assets.
For example, if you have a bunch of textures selected
and you want to enable or disable sRGB,
this tool is great for that.
If you need to set all of the light map settings
for a group of static meshes, this tool is great for that.
We can also change MIP GIN settings,
LOD or filtering options.
There's a lot that we can do.
Now to access this tool,
all we need to do is come to the editor.
So I'm gonna hit control space.
I'm actually gonna enable my textures filter
and then inside the search, I'm gonna hit underscore N.
This is just gonna isolate me some normal maps
to work with.
Then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna select
all of these normal maps by just hitting shift.
Oops, I got a little bit too more.
So I'm gonna grab this one, go down here and hit shift.
And then I'm gonna right click
and give this just a second here.
There we go, right click asset actions
and then edit section selection and property matrix.
There we go.
So over here is the properties that we have exposed
that we want to adjust and the pinned column over here,
we can find all of the things that we want here.
So if I do something like this, hold shift,
we're gonna look for VIR virtual texture.
Today I want to enable virtual texture streaming.
I could just click this little check mark box here
and now I've enabled virtual texture streaming
for all of those textures and there we go.
I have actually disabled it.
So this is a really, really great tool
for doing things just like that.
Now, a couple of things to consider.
With performance, if you selected a large number of assets,
the update process might take a little while
and it may even appear that the editor
has frozen or crashed, but don't worry,
it's still processing it in the background.
Just give it time to complete.
The property matrix is often used for textures,
but it also supports many other asset types
that you can select from the content browser,
such as material, sounds and animation.
So it's a great general purpose tool
for bulk editing across a variety of content.
With that said, you need to make sure
that you select assets that are all of the same type.
So if you're gonna be working with textures,
you need to make sure you have all of textures selected.
If you have, say, a static mesh or a material selected,
you're gonna notice that none of the properties
that you're used to seeing are gonna be there.
And that's, again, because certain options
aren't available across all asset types.
So you need to make sure that you do have
all of the same asset type selected.
There are also not all settings are exposed
to the property matrix.
For example, LOD settings for static meshes
and some advanced configuration options
aren't available through this tool.
So if you need to bulk edit assets with those properties,
you'll need to use editor utility blueprints
or the static mesh editor subsystem.
So remember that we can use bulk editing
for large scale property changes quickly,
efficiently and reliably.
Be patient with large selections.
And remember that you can only operate
on assets of the same type.
So only on materials, only on textures,
only on static meshes.
We're now gonna take a look at packed level instances
as they are a really useful tool
that allows you to kit bash large scale environments
by assembling them from smaller reusable pieces.
And we can actually see an example of that
in the image that we're seeing right here.
This image on the right hand side was created
using all of these rock sandstone meshes
and various rotations, scales and transforms.
Once we were happy with the overall result,
we selected all of them.
And then from the selection menu,
we selected this packed level instance blueprint.
What this is gonna do is then it's gonna give us
a actor that actually contains all of those meshes
that we can quickly place in any level.
And one of the other added benefits of this
is that it's actually gonna replace
all of the static meshes in there
with instanced static mesh versions,
which makes things run a little bit faster.
Now let's pop over into the editor right now
and kind of have a look at how this works.
So here we have just a simple box set up.
And the reason that I have two of them
is there's actually two versions of this tool.
And the version that you select
depends on what is contained in your selection.
So first off, if we select all of our static mesh,
anything that's static that doesn't require
say a trigger volume or some type of gameplay
or something like that, if we select all of them,
we right click and we come down to our level.
This is where we're gonna create a packed level actor.
So we can click on this.
It's gonna ask us where we want the pivot to be placed.
Right now I'm just gonna do the center minimum Z
and press okay.
And we are gonna call this and press save.
And then it's gonna ask us
where we wanna save the blueprint version of this.
And we're gonna go ahead and just let it be to the default.
And what we're gonna get is
this is our packed level blueprint.
Now there's a couple of cool things
that we could do with this.
If we right click on it and we come to the level,
we can edit it.
And then inside of here, we can do things like this.
And if I press save, what's gonna happen
is all of them are gonna be updated.
But the other cool thing that we can do
is these are meant to be nested
inside of other configurations.
So I'm just gonna flip these around like this,
flip all the way around and just move it over like so.
So there we go.
So what we could do too is we can right click on this
and go to level and go create packed level actor.
And then we'll call this one pack two and press save.
And then we'll save this as well.
And now what we've got is, well, that's pack one,
but this is pack two.
And if we, whoops, if we right click on this
and we go to our level, we can actually edit this
and you can see here, we can also right click on this
and go to our level and then edit this one.
Whoops, level and level and edit.
Let's just do that one more time.
There we go.
And now we can edit the individual one.
So I can put something like this and then save
and it's gonna update like it did over there.
So that's really cool.
We can actually nest these so that when we
are editing them, we can make massive edits
across the entire world.
And the other cool thing is if we want to use these,
say as a starting point, we can even come here
to our level and we can break them.
And what that's gonna do is it's gonna break this
in it to its individual components.
Further break these down by just going here
to break and break.
Yes, and there we go.
We've actually broken this down into the individual pieces.
So we can use these again as a great starting point
or once we have, then once we're done,
we can always repack them back into something else.
Now, there is one other version of these.
And if I select all of these objects here,
like so and I get the light and I right click,
we're gonna go to level and we're gonna create
a level instance.
So the difference between the two is that
the level instanced can actually contain things
like blueprints or triggers or lights.
We are gonna call this level instance underscore zero one
and click save.
And again, the major difference is that we are just going
to, if I was to hit control B to look at this,
we are getting this level here that I can pull in,
but we don't actually get a blueprint like we did
in the other one.
And again, remember the reason that we have two of them
or the different versions is that the packed level actor
is for things that are static, that aren't gonna move,
maybe a massive building or a bunch of rocks
or things like that.
The level actor itself is for when we have something
that is gonna require some type of blueprint interaction.
Maybe there's a light or something like that.
So we wanna use that one if we ever want to, again,
have something that contains something else
other than a static mesh.
So which one you use depends on the needs of your project.
You can use a mix of both of them.
You can use just primarily level packed actors,
or you can use primarily level instance.
It really is up to the needs of your project.
And the last thing that I do want to mention
is that these are meant to be used in conjunction
with world partition.
And when you're using them,
remember that they're meant to be used as modular blocks.
So nesting is encouraged
and will help you get the most out of this system.